khiến yêu cầu của bộ nội vụ các tình thành phố đang lần lượt báo cáo tình hình tình lương thường tết tại xanh nghiệp.
Thống K-dính ngày 22, mức tưởng tết cao nhất chùi yếu thuộc hối xanh nghiệp có vốn đầu tự nước ngoài,
cho khi mức tắc nhất chỉ ở mức vài trả muy động.
Theo báo cáo của sở nội vụ các địa phương, mức tưởng tết âm lịch cao nhất được khi nhận tại tây ninh với sáo trăm triệu đồng,
tiếp đến là khán hoạch 20 năm mấy triệu đồng.
Một số địa phương khác như ninh vình hả tính cả mâu cũng đi nhận mức thường cao từ 1 trăm triệu 2 đến 2 trăm sáo mấy triệu đồng,
cho khi mức tắc nhất phổ biến từ không phải mỗi đến không phải nằm triệu đồng.
Tại ngày an khảo sát gần về nìn muốn trăm xanh nghiệp cho thấy tên lương bình quân năm 2020,
đặt bày phay nằm triệu đồng 1 người 1 tháng, thường tết dứng lịch bình quân 1 phải tắn làm triệu đồng,
còn thường tết biến nọc đặt bình quân 1 phải chính bày triệu đồng, với mức cao nhất thuộc về lau đồng trong dân nghiệp ADI.
Ở khảnh hoa, tên lương bình quân đặt 1 2 phải tắn triệu đồng 1 người 1 tháng,
thường tết dứng lịch bình quân 2 phải bày triệu đồng, hơn năm 2020 gẹp có kế hoạch thường tết biến nọc,
với mức bình quân trên chiến phy bốn triệu đồng trong đó hôm ước cao nhất thuộc về lau đồng ADI.
Trước đó, bố nội vụ đã có yêu cầu các địa phương khảo sát,
nắm tình hình tình lương lượng lượng quanh hiện lau đồng năm 2020, cũng như kế hoạch thường dị tết dứng lịch và tết mình đã năm 2020,
báo cáo về bộ nội vụ trước kẻ hai làm tháng 12 năm 2020.